everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we are in round
number six of the 2019 a US Chess
Championships it's been a good one so
far in our competitors today we got
white being played by Fabiano Caruana
he is the highest rated American
currently he's also the second highest
rated chess player in the world behind
Magnus Carlsen no surprise that they
faced off last year for the World
Championship there were all drawls and
then Magnus Carlsen did go on to win the
tiebreaker Fabiano a very strong player
he's up against Jeffrey's Young so one
of the youngsters in the tournament so
we'll see how this fares Fabiano just a
couple days ago extended his winless
streak in classical chess to his age for
anyone watching and following along and
the social universe Magnus Carlsen was
trolling him a little bit on Twitter
saying that it is a life goal to reach a
winless streak that equals your age
poking fun at Fabiano Caruana so Fabiano
definitely looking to break that streak
and get a victory here Jeffrey on the
other side playing the black pieces
would love nothing more than to continue
that streak and even come out with a
victory so we'll go ahead and get into
it starts out with pawn to e4 pawn e5
Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop to b5 getting
into the Rui Lopez Knight to f6 the
Birdland offense and then pawn to d3 so
not the most common line that we're used
to seeing we covered earlier match which
was pawn to d4 which we assumed more
often but Fabiano does like to play more
of the pond e3 move Bishop comes down
here to a c5 and then Bishop takes on c6
and after the pawn recaptures we have
Fabiano cats going on at the kingside
the board black continues with Queen to
e7 wants to make sure that he defends
this pawn on e5 currently being attacked
by the knight here on F three Knights to
d2 now normal development moved Knight
to c3 but really wants to add pressure
to this pawn on e5 so wants to play
Knight to d2 and then eventually bring
it here
to see four so that both the Knights are
it's hacking the square here on e5 so
that's why we're seeing Knight - D -
Bishop down to G for pinning down the
knight - the Queen pend age three
forcing the bishop to come back here and
then pawn to e3 just does not want any
material to come down to a b4 and also
just once to be able to push forward
with pawn to b4 at some point forcing
the bishop to move pawn down here to a5
recognizing exactly what Fabiana is
looking to do wants to stop this threat
from coming up here to B form so Fabiana
continues with what we expected after we
played niceties who when he plays Knight
here to c4 White has both of his Knights
attacking this pond right here Geoffrey
decides he needs to add another defender
so it brings his knight back here to d7
has both his knight Amos queen defending
this pawn
Fabiana has multiple options here as far
as how he wants to continue he could
just continue normal simple development
Queen to e to get his dark square Bishop
bulb to the game but many times if your
opponent starts to retreat material
that's an opportunity for you to push
forward put a lot of pressure on them
that's exactly what Fabiano does he
plays pawn to g4 forcing the bishop to
move back here to g6 and then pawn to b4
Bishop retreats again did have the
opportunity to take this if he wanted to
couldn't just retake then he would lose
his rook right here but maybe if he
wanted to bring his bishop up here start
to attack just give up that material he
could instead decided against that plays
Bishop here to b6 takes with this pawn
Bishop's going to recapture and then
Bishop here - b2 so adding another
attacker on the square here on e5 this
does for spawn to f6 so not the best
pawn structure for black piquancy
Fabiana has already pushed two pawns
ahead on his king sided board that's not
necessarily something that has to worry
about and since the light square bishop
is off the board for whites you know
pushing this pawn and opening up for
these light squares to be attacked not
as big of a threat that black is
worrying about Knight takes here on a5
works gonna recapture here Knight to h4
attacking the bishop then
castle on the Kings side of the board
now white does have the option to take
this bishop probably not the best option
though this is more of a closed position
so Knights are gonna do pretty well
after the Knight takes here the pawn
recaptures no there's no clear way that
White's gonna be able to get his
material over here on the Kings side of
the board maybe if he had castle down
the Queen side I could definitely see
they start to push all your pawns bring
your Brooks over here to the Kings side
that makes more sense but right now you
probably want to hold on to one of your
Knights and that's exactly what Fabiana
does and instead decides to play Knight
over here to f5 now if there is an
exchange great you could play pawn to f5
if you want to really load up the King
side with all of your pawns but after
Knight to f5 and then we see the Queen
to e6 play continues with King to h2
pawn c5 so opening up the door for
Fabiana to bring his rooks over here
specifically g1 pond to h4 and this is
getting tricky I don't know that I like
White's position too much here you can
just blow this up and then you have an
exposed King right here so Fabiano
absolutely has to be tricky do you ever
gonna be looking for ways to attack here
now plays pawn to c4 trying to blow
things up pawn to h5 now attacking the
bishop [ __ ] comes back to f7 rook to g1
as we thoughts pawn takes pawn
recaptures here on d3 so there's no a
backward pawn here on d3 that Geoffrey
can attack at some point now rook to b5
attacking the bishop bishop comes down
here to see one and then King to h8 and
as tricky as far as how black really
continues here yes he wants to attack
the King side because once these pawns
go off the King's very exposed but he
also has to worry about all the attacks
that Fabiano has he wants to get his
Queen involvement to the game but where
does he really go huh he doesn't want to
go backwards when he can't come to e7
because he would lose it to the knight
can't come to d6 he would lose it to the
knight can't come here to c6 cuz he
would just lose with the fork here if he
does come to Queen to b6 you know trying
to I down to this pawn here on f2 then
Bishop to e3 this is a better square for
the bishop the Queen's gonna have to
move maybe comes back here because
there's no good squares pawn to a4 and
really white just got to free moves in
this position okay so maybe we come back
and instead of the Queen moving maybe
try to get the the knight involved so
Knight to c5 that just doesn't do too
much pawn to g5 this is exactly what
white one starts to blow up the King
side of the board and all of a sudden
black has one less piece involved in the
action so that's not gonna be at the end
of the day just decides okay there's
gonna be a lot of action on this G file
so I'm gonna go ahead and get my King
over here to AJ it seems like the safest
square miss should be e3
exactly where we thought it would be
rook down here to b3 it's hacking this
backwards pawn here really the only
thing that Geoffrey has going for him
right now
rook to g3 pawn down here to c5 it's
being protected currently by the Knights
on at d7 Queen to e2 Bishop down or
excuse me pawn down here to g5 and
really you know with on passant have one
opportunity to take this pretty much has
to take it because he needs to blow up
this side of the board to start his
attack so that's exactly what white does
pawn takes and then the bishop captures
do not want to capture it with the pawn
right here too many bad things can
happen
rook to h3 the King moves and then King
to d2 preparing for the rook to come
over to h1 there's just no way to really
stop this you can almost sense that this
black Bishop here is just blocking a lot
of the move so maybe the rook moves over
here to eight eight eight to allow some
breathing room for the king
rook to h1 King f8 so you can see how
bad things are gonna go from here so did
correctly decide to go ahead and take
with the bishop here on g6 pawn to a4 so
putting pressure on the Queen side of
the board as well here
Queen to a6 both stopping this pawn from
pushing but also adding another attacker
on the backward pawn here on d3 both the
rook and
Queen are now attacking that Bishop to
age six attacking the rook rook to g8
just in peer defense mode I feel like we
see this a lot in chess or one side just
putting a lot of pressure the other side
just has to stay back play as much
defense as possible and hope that things
don't go terribly wrong for them
we're over here to g1 the attack has
begun here Queens takes on a fourth that
is completely fine that's not what
Fabiano's worrying about right now
Knight up here to e7 attacking the rook
Queen to d4 just centralizing the Queen
Queen down here to d1 attacking the rook
here and then pawn to c4 and this is
definitely a questionable move attacking
the rook the knight up here on a 7 is
also attacking the rook and just miss
calculates I think he really needs to be
moving this rook away the pawn here on
c4 is not the way to go after the knight
takes the King recaptures now the pawn
can take this is never discovered attack
against the Queen here if the Queen
falls yeah there's an easy exchange on
the board why it's gonna be up in
material there's just no way to do this
effectively Geoffrey decides his best
route is to go ahead and take the rook
here Queen takes the pawns gonna take
and then the King taking here so left
with a rookie and a bishop against a
bishop and eight nights yes the bishop
is able to come down here to e4 and take
metier but getting into the endgame the
rook is just too strong here even though
black does have the pawn advantage so
they continue rook to d1 pawn down here
to d3 now attacking the bishop bishop
comes back but that's fine to work over
here to a-1 and then getting it to the
seventh rank so deadly deadly especially
in the endgame to get your rook to your
opponent's seventh ranked knight here to
c5 defending both pawns so that's a nice
little square for the knight but the
bishop on e3 it's just no way really to
stop that the Knights gonna have to move
or just leave the pawn can't come in to
b6 where he would like to that would
defend this night because that would be
an illegal move so there's no good way
for
like to continue here decided to go
ahead and play King t8 just getting out
of the way of the check but he does lose
his Knights here
pawn down here to d2 to recognize that
his only option is just to go ahead and
get the Queen down here on a d1 rook to
a8 check bishop here to b6 says yeah I
don't mind if you bring your pawn down
here and get to a queen because I'll
just swing my rook over here to d8 check
bishops defending that and you would
lose the Queen
so in this board state Geoffrey decided
to play King here to c6 and then we're
met with the great move of Bishop here
to a5 and it's a disposition the
Geoffrey decided to resign this is a
great little position because there's no
real square for black to go to if he
decides to you know do anything besides
move the pawn here then the bishop is
just gonna take the pawn here on d2 but
if he does move his pawn here let's say
he gets that Queen then rook to c8 and
this Bishop and the pawn are working
together in tandem with the rook here
that the King cannot move on this C file
or the B file has to come over here to
the D file and then rook to d8 doesn't
matter where the King goes and as soon
as the King moves then the Queen is
going to fall so really really
phenomenal it'd be curious to know how
far back Fabiano thought about this
position and how crucial this pawn here
on c4 would be to these very very
precise calculations but at the end of
the day he did break the streak he now
has won a classical game so he can go
back and tweet back at Magnus Carlsen
that the streak has been broken so
phenomenal from him Geoffrey played a
good game and there was a place where I
thought he had the better position but
at the end just was not able to
capitalize on the weakness that Fabiano
had on the King side of the board so
that is round number 6 definitely puts
Fabiano back in contention if he can
start to rattle off some wins here
hopefully you guys enjoyed
around number six and I will catch you
later on the tournaments
thanks for watching bye